Dean Gary Vee just texted questions and
the stress because you're 17 Gary
[Music]
hello world good morning good afternoon
if you're in Europe good evening if
you're in Asia April 7th Tuesday morning
I got my big [ __ ] mug it is tea with
Gary B and I'm super thrilled that
you're here with me thank you so much
before we get into it grab out your
phones immediately do one of two things
take a screenshot of this right now
and share it I just tweeted it if you're
part of the tea with Gary B community
and you're not on Twitter interacting
with me at Gary Vee you're making a huge
mistake
following retweeting engaging and
building a real community I just tweeted
the URL to YouTube where this is live
and please retweet that and add your two
cents get everybody on here
before we get into the cause big
shoutouts to all the comments right now
let's take a look farah naaz what's good
Kareem what's good on Facebook deep fact
on YouTube what is a Tyler a cliff real
real good morning to you like what
you're doing dust and get these comments
up hardcore right off the bat back sore
what's up Barry Eisenbach really nice to
have you here thank you so much Jonathan
Johnson what's good chef what's good
Tony
what is up really excited to have
everybody here our hunter what's good
Chris Quinn this is a lot of fun also
big big opportunity today if you drink
rose a rose I put up right here one of
the best California roses dismantles
whispering angel if you are not on wine
texts you're making a huge mistake
yesterday was crazy 20 minutes we sold
out of that cab that I was telling you
about
today's offer brain and I worked on for
months one of the best roses $30 Rose a
at a ridiculous price I'm really excited
about it should sell out within 20
minutes as well so if you drink or Jose
if you need some Rose a during this
quarantine I highly recommend you get on
wine Tex right now get that off let's
get to the first call this is tea with
Gary B rock dance theater what's good
morning hey good morning what's your
name were you from hey I don't
any tea but I'm trying to wake up I'm
trying to get I get it it's early I
appreciate the hustle 6 a.m. I
appreciate it yeah yeah thank you so
much for having me I have a question for
you
so on my social platforms for a while
I've been making great videos and I've
been like building such a cool community
but any time I switch something up they
sort of like throw a fit like I get like
a lot of I miss the old hair comments
and I wanted to know like is there
something I'm doing wrong is there
something I'm not doing that could make
us kind of grow together better like I
don't want to leave them hanging what
were the videos you were making and what
what are some of the stuff you're mixing
in yeah so so I primarily make dance
videos and I do a lot of like robotics
and a lot of like tutting and things
like that and let's say I didn't cut a
lot in a video or I dance music they're
freaking out they're like I just miss
the old you know like I just show did I
get it did it did I went through this
hard hard in 2009 so I did three years
every day five days a week on early
YouTube wine videos I was one of the
first youtubers that especially doing
long-form and it was all wine and then I
was like you know I want to talk about
business cuz that's really what I am and
I started making business videos and
people [ __ ] lost their mind out of
anger you know like just didn't like it
any time that I've taken a step in my
business career like got a TV appearance
or got a had a viral micro viral video
or like popped off or like hung out with
somebody immediately people like you're
different you changed we miss this we
miss that the reality is the reality is
you can't get caught up in the comments
or the likes or views you just can't you
have to evolve and they have to follow
you and you have that conviction i watch
so many people not change their [ __ ] up
even though they want to because they
don't like the fact that they get more
negative comments and they get less
engagement it's a huge mistake like
you've got to stay the course like
you're going through your life you can't
be the same girl you were three years
ago and yeah I cannot
and your self-esteem in your self-worth
can't be how many followers or how much
engagement you get on Instagram
it just can't yeah and right now we're
in a generation where people are
starting to think that way
right yeah it's a it's a scary thing I
mean when we're living off these brand
deals and like that's how we pay around
like it's really easy for me to get
paranoid about it I'm at a point now
where I'm comfortable and I'm ready to
say like like I'll let my engagement go
down and I'll do this I just don't like
my own content a hundred percent and I
promise you when you like your own
content that [ __ ] comes back so often
especially if you have talent Wow thank
you listen and another thing you can
live in it you can live I'd rather you
live in a little less fancy apartment
I'd rather you buy one less nice thing
go on one less trip and [ __ ] be
unhappy you know right we have to make
happiness the [ __ ] North Star not
[ __ ] money right we have to and you
have a responsibility of a huge fanbase
and so you have to show and lead the way
and then make a video about it be like
you know I love you [ __ ] but I am
changing - right yeah speak to them do
your [ __ ] and then the sixth video be
like I love you I'm so grateful for you
but I'm evolving and so are you and like
let's you know and I appreciate him by
the way I'll [ __ ] pop-and-lock for
you and once in a blue moon for old
time's sakes but I gotta do my I swear
exactly and you can you can bring it out
of the blue moon you know right good
luck thank you for having up so early
today yeah alright let's keep this going
tea with Gary Vee please share it scream
shoot it let's get people in here I know
there's some Facebook groups watching
big shout out to everybody
reddit big shout out to you LinkedIn I
know you're in the building big shout
out to all of you guys as well samuel on
facebook what's good hi hi hi how are
you good morning
good morning hi I'm Brooklyn a queen
from Detroit I'm 14
in answer so my question for you is what
would you tell like what advice would
you give your 14 year old self based on
everything that you know now so my
advice might be a little bit tricky for
you but I'll give it to you and then if
I can give you a follow-up I'll let you
know for me it would have been like look
it's okay
14 was a real big year for me because
it's when my baseball card business
started to really pop and my dad dragged
me into the liquor store and I was
working every weekend and every summer
vacation so I was like in a real
transition where I was like okay now I'm
grown and I'm doing business like [ __ ]
school so really the advice I would have
given that kid is like this is gonna be
such an enjoyable part of your life
you're about to learn so many of the
skills that you're gonna use the rest of
your life so enjoy that I probably would
have told him not to go 100 into
business and save and really push back
against his dad and himself and and have
a little bit of summer vacation maybe
two weeks to hang out with friends but
um but honestly that was a big
transition year for me and and was
really the year that like my career
started in a lot of ways right what
about for you let's let's instead of
that question what about for you what is
the most challenging part of being for
this young and having this much
attention on you a most challenging part
are you happy happy happy yes this is
like my dream this is probably this is
definitely gonna be the thing that I do
for the rest of my life um so can I tell
you something I'll give you something
that I think could really help don't
don't get too high on the positive
feedback when you read the comments and
people like you're amazing you're pretty
you're smart you're amazing you're so
talented don't get too high on that
because what that's gonna do is let you
deal when people say your [ __ ] you fell
off you're not good when you start
getting quiet and it's about you for you
not the audience's feedback I think it
will put you in a much more stable place
to go and do your thing right like when
people you know
come on my page with the negative the
negative things
um I I'm just the type of person that
like cuz being a public figure you're
gonna get bullied every day on social
media like on your lives on your post on
everything so I'm just the type of
person that I wouldn't say don't care
but I just don't feed into the to the
negative energies epic um I love that
end and as a matter of fact if you can
start this at 14 it'll put you in such a
great spot you should like if you can
flip it from not caring to actually
having compassion to that person right
for somebody to go on your page and try
to drag you down they're [ __ ] hurt
and inside yeah you understand that and
I'll sometimes even like someone could
comment something like you're disgusting
or you're ugly and then I go to their
page and I like a picture and then
they're like oh my gosh
you know thank you so much so they'd
like to turn into a supporter listen if
you one of the biggest things that
helped me was my ability to be the
bigger man when people came at me with
heat and negativity
I always did stuff like that I was like
look I'm sorry like you know that you
feel that way but I wish you happiness
and health
I'd go give them love like that I used
to go in there be like I love that about
you if you've got that now you're on
your way just try not to get too high
trying to get too low and always always
create never hold back like don't never
ever ever not put out your voice your
thoughts keep staring cuz you never know
when a thought your head that you didn't
put out was actually the thought that
would change the world so the last piece
before we bounce here is make sure you
put out the content don't overthink the
music don't overthink the videos put
what's in your [ __ ] heart in your
head yes thank you thank you thanks for
watching
thank you for joining me in yep talk to
you soon that girl's mind is right at 14
she's gonna win that girl is gonna win
that's a lock I'm excited for her Danny
waters with good Marianne said imbrie
know what's good
Jay Thomas love you back Metcalfe's meet
the Metcalfe's what's up ginger beloved
so good to see you big shadow it seems
on Twitter hello hello good morning
wonderful my name is Tara Mackey I'll
give you a little bit of backstory to
frame my question because I have a
question for you I have two best-selling
books I have an organic beauty company I
am an influencer I sing I speak which is
all wonderful but I have to pivot a lot
of that business model this year because
I can't sing live I can't speak live
retail is kind of out right now so I'm
focused 100% on my e-commerce business
so we're focused right now on education
the education around the products since
it's organic beauty products the
education around staying safe and where
do you see anxiety and what's going on
in the world today and we're starting up
a very large ambassador program we're
sending out emails two or three times a
week we're updating our Instagram two or
three times a day I want to know if you
have any specific advice for at this
point in time building a recession smart
because I don't know if there's any such
thing as recession proof that our
session smart business in this time of
such uncertainty about what the world's
gonna look like in the next few months
in the next year etc so first of all
it's really running a business that has
a real good grasp of its overhead and
its profit margins right so really
looking at your expenses first of all
because a lot of good entrepreneurs and
good influencers are very good at
focusing on the offense but they're not
as strong at looking at the bottom line
so a definitely definitely looking at
your economics you know how profitable
or the products you're selling on the
e-commerce site and and then you know
who's who's surrounding you right in in
the world of influences that nature too
many people have too many assistants too
many content creators to many glam squad
so being very thoughtful about that
right and then and then really it's
about building
for the fun'll brand awareness during
this time I actually think that the
economy is gonna be I don't know what
kind of recession were really looking at
I think the biggest variable that nobody
knows is what happens with the pandemic
the disease during the fall and winter
how much or how little does it come back
right and how you know to me that's the
biggest thing that's on my mind
but I think you should definitely assume
to bunker down for a year right at a
hardcore year and I think in that year
tightening up the expenses and then also
really focusing on expansion so where
are you at with with tik-tok I just
hopped down there probably like a month
ago and what are you doing zero a day
one a day for days I'm mostly learning
what other people are doing and where I
can best create content that actually
serves people and isn't just me learning
some viral dance which does nothing for
anybody right so it's or you know I you
know I've got 3.3 million followers and
a huge audience there and I talk forever
by the way you have been oh gee to talk
for like probably since the day it came
out you have been telling people about
tick tock on every platform so I
appreciate that and and and I haven't
and I can't dance for [ __ ] and so and
I'm and I think you don't need to either
you have to immediately listen to me hey
when when did you get on Instagram and
and what happened I probably got
Instagram in 2014 my first my first book
came out in 2016 but I got my book deal
in 2014 my publishing company reached
out they found my blog so 2016 I got
like great PR for my first book becoming
a number one bestseller and not
attracted a large Instagram audience and
then it really built from there but I
found that engagement is going down
numbers are good you know it goes didn't
happen every platform yeah it's already
happening on tick-tock
so the people I got on tick-tock 15
months ago is it really yes you have to
listen to me yeah you you have to post
two three times a day on tick-tock okay
okay you have like
like today okay not it's so important
there's so much up and let me tell you
why it's important there's still land
grab it's not as crazy as it was you
know 15 months ago like anybody could
oppose something and went viral now but
but you it's time to post and more
importantly the things you're gonna
learn in posting the next platform
I mean YouTube's working on the tic-tock
competitor right now and YouTube's a
wildly important platform whether that
pops or not everything evolves
everything so Socialcam led to buying a
vine you know led to you know snapchat
snapchat the interim story isn't instant
like it all about you can't skip over
being a creator for tick-tock because
being a creator and putting out content
is going to be forever yeah make me make
ready make make what you make on
Instagram and [ __ ] right over just
[ __ ] make you know one [ __ ]
Instagram either just one of the things
that catches people is when you're
successful for the first time on another
platform they struggle with the
perception of not being big on the
current platform and and I want to get
you out of it that's why celebrities got
[ __ ] they all didn't go on Instagram
in 2013 14 15 16 17 because they were
real celebrities and then all of a
sudden Instagram celebrities became real
celebrities they got caught yeah and now
they're all in tip-top you have to do it
you have to do it thank you economics
and costs on your retail yeah and really
go ham I'm tick-tock I'm telling you it
work awesome thank you alright let's
keep this going Dustin I'm gonna do
tonight I'm like all four ladies in a
row this is amazing
it's ladies morning I love this Jackie
what's good hey how are you well I come
to you from Wichita Falls Texas and it's
thank you um it's so great I Drive into
the city to run my advertising agency
but I live on a farm with house
dairy farmers daughter and a dairy
farmers why it's so good to just drive
in and see the sunrise but I can't thank
you enough for spending just a few
minutes with me this morning my question
today is you know our agency is very
heartfelt and aggressive and what I love
most about you is you're an open book to
every agency across the United States
you teach us your craft and we dive in
and we learn it and we absorb it we are
two weeks into a shelter city and all of
our local clients are getting antsy and
there their anxiety has gone up a level
Gary and there's nervous so now they're
thinking Jackie I know you're telling us
to double down on social media and tell
our story Jackie you there but did I
lose you
I'm your back you can you hear me Double
Down tell your story almost okay
sorry about that okay so what I need is
Gary is how do I tell these local
clients don't give up now's not the time
to give up you got to stay the course
keep telling your story does that make
sense it does I want some clarification
are we talking about organic creative or
you asking them to run media
amplification you can't hear me we're
gonna get you on Jackie you can here
turn it off we'll get you back on that's
we're both try reloading the page and
then come back and then we'll be we'll
be here okay I'll come right back you
will get a J all right I'm gonna give
some shoutouts while Jackie's trying to
get back out big shout out to Emily Nate
Nate dizzy on on Facebook never give up
hitting record numbers in sales right
now good job I appreciate that let's
take a little break right now and
everybody take a screen shot and share
this let's get that going I am feeling
on fire Vince Lester big shout out to
you part of the YouTube community I
appreciate that
Caleb Dustin is putting in work I agree
Carl Daniel Davidson what's good there
tirado Tyler Ratliff what's good she is
awesome Jeremy I'm excited to get her
right back Jr softly I love that Jersey
sure let's go hey thank you Gary for
letting me come back I'm welcome can you
hear me yes I can I think that was my
dad call it in by the way I love it
shout out today so the question that I
have is are you telling them to double
down on organic content or you asking
them to double down on media spend on
their on their or on their social or
other channels yeah I think organic is
so important today
but with a little bit of spend but your
message I you know I tell them that
their message changes you have to be
more authentic today than ever and speak
from the heart and they they're just
nervous you know every time they think
are we in this for 30 days 60 days now
they're saying August we have to save
every penny we've got and I go get it I
guess is this a conversation of them
wanting to potentially stop the scope
with you for a time being yes look I
think look I think you have to be
correct you have to find it you have to
be very balanced here Oh Jack I like
hold on hold on can you cut Popeye we
got some big pink up mugs I like that
listen you're gonna have to eat your own
dog food here you also are gonna have to
be courageous I've had a ton of
conversations with clients that are
teetering and the reality is when you're
talking to small businesses and
obviously we have the Sasha group and
things that nature you you have to be
empathetic you yourself for a small
business and first and foremost you have
to worry about your business your
employees however when you're giving
advice you actually have to give advice
so what I would do if I were you is dig
a double-click into the condo if you
figure out that Sarah with her you know
flower shop does have the savings that
the financial wherewithal to get through
you know two years well then Sarah's
opportunity to go crazy right now if
Rick
it in the thrift store is in a little
bit more of a financial pickle the
advice might be to say to Rick listen
why don't you pay me half you know for
the next three months
let's get you know like you have to be
empathetic and you have to tighten up
yourself your advice during this time to
the people that pay you is something
that will be your reputation and your
financial impact for the next three
decades yeah so yeah you know because
you know how it is if they're paying you
and they're on the phone and they're
feeling like the only reason you're
giving you the advice is so that you're
still paying that's gonna change the
dynamic so you have to dig a little bit
deeper I spent 45 minutes with every
client to really understand and some of
them I said look it is a good time for
you to pause I don't like what I'm
hearing that was at my detriment short
term sure I may have to have a lay up I
may have to cut expenses but it's the
right advice and for the reputation and
the legacy and most of all for me
putting my [ __ ] head on my pillow it
was the right advice yeah and that's if
akyuu can't be you can't be everybody
needs to triple down if they have one
month's worth of cash and they're
burning it that is not the right advice
they need to cut all expenses if they
are in a little bit more of a stable
situation they should triple down
because [ __ ] prices of ads on
Instagram and Facebook right now are so
low because a lot of people have stopped
there's so much opportunity okay that
makes sense
and you know it's and it's also your
team it's loving on your team in your
office and giving them the support as
well you know they're all doubling down
too and giving up everything they have
you know we just we just want to be
there for our clients we just want to
walk this with them and in the end come
out altogether loving and hugging on
each other sometimes being there is
telling them to spend less with you
sometimes that's the truth okay I got it
and by the way some that can afford to
go harder might double up their scope
once they see how big the opportunity is
yeah share of mind no doubt Jackie the
right advice is always selfless yeah
always you know especially especially
when it's hardest
yeah and I mean it doesn't surprise me
that you're saying that as many times as
I've gotten to cross paths and be in
your office and kindness you know when I
came in for 4d you know what my biggest
surprise was after all day in your
office my biggest surprise was and I
wasn't expecting it was the advice and
the love that not only we got from your
whole team but quad you know just the
love and the warmth that she gave us
that day I took that home and wet
that's ice we're gonna become an office
of empathy kindness love compassion and
we're gonna double down and love every
single day of these clients and every
single day with this team and it works
right right now is when it shines
through right now is all that you know
it's funny because I'm an aggressive
Jersey kid so it's a little bit harder
to you know to your point until you kind
of come into the you four walls even you
know you'll just never people will never
fully get it by watching my content it's
very deep the stuff I talk about I
really mean it I'd live it and I love
the transparency of sharing it so for
all agencies out there thank you so much
for being interested thank you bye bye
everybody's watching what Jackie is
referring to is one of the most unique
things I'm doing is because I'm putting
out all my best advice for free there's
a lot of my competitors you know the
Sasha group works with small businesses
too like I'm educating a lot of my
competitors for free and that is a very
unusual model definitely in the ad world
in in business and so you see it from
being a community but in my direct
competitive and scape I'm a very
interesting enigma people are confused
by it
some people like Jackie really get it a
lot of people hate because we've
exploded and what a bit weird a
fastest-growing and concerning everybody
but it's really cool it's really cool
all right let's keep it going fun
morning Joe what's good Gary
I'm just pumped there's a dude on here
now we would before let me listen I love
the ladies that we met the ladies day
but it's good to see a dude as well so
Joe what's up it's good to see you man
I'm glad I'm here so let me just try and
dive in I
my question needs a little bit of
prerequisite first just to explain so we
own a chain of eight higher end barber
shops of New Jersey we started in 2009
my brother was 19 years old when he
started it I want to say back in 2016 I
left a six-figure job full-time to work
on the business full-time since then
we've brought on partners that have been
our barbers especially our one partner
Isaac as partners with us in everything
and we've created we're beginning to
create what it was is a brand of eight
barber shops but a culture in
environment it's not just a barber shop
basically we provide our employees with
an environment where they can grow where
our clients can feel like family so it's
not just a barber shop so basically what
I want to say is this what I've been
into too much is in this industry
especially with our model we pay our
barbers really well and we work on
commission based our barbers are full
w-2 employees so on top of that we have
payroll taxes on top of rent and any
overhead you would think so our more
we're really low so in this industry
because we're trying to build a brand
continue to grow we basically my
question is how can what can we do
besides have a normal product line which
we already started and about a year and
a half ago we've hired a full-time
videographer to create content
constantly on Instagram YouTube Facebook
everything and besides all that how can
we use how can we utilize the
connections that we're getting through
our clients who love our brand to
generate a bigger profit in other
avenues so that we can continue to grow
more rapidly than bootstrapping one
after another after another because if
we only focus on just very difficult why
do we want to grow more well because
that's our goal is not to just stay in
Jersey our goal is to grow as brand how
old are you 34 okay so you have 50
[ __ ] years to go to Cleveland
what what do you see sighs we start you
do you do know what happens in this
cliche right bootstrappers young
hustlers do it right brick by brick
brick by brick brick brick brick catch
something they can feel it I feel it
like I pulled you out of the comments to
be on fright I feel it and then their
eyes get big they start hearing chirping
from people that are not in their inner
circle right there uncle their most
successful high school buddy the the guy
who's getting this haircut
that's a [ __ ] millionaire on Wall
Street and people start chirping and
what happens is they start to get
impatient we lost you there for a second
I want to make sure you hear this now
there you go I can hear you now
so can you hear me yeah so they start
getting impatient right so what's also
happening is a lot of people especially
clients for successful are complete
asking their brand the reason let's get
the next one let's get him back on let's
keep this going well that be a part too
because it's about to get good Roland
Edwards what's good
whoa Nicky hey what's up like it's good
where you from from Ogden Utah fantastic
sweet so hey man um quick backstory to
my question so about two years ago I
went to college for a year I dropped out
I joined a real estate sales team to
start stone houses um the leader of the
team approached me one day he said hey I
want you to run my social media page so
I started running the social media page
and little did I know is that he had
another side of the real estate side he
had an Academy where he taught agents
how to sell houses
so also having a team on the side y'all
still tall agent Hollister houses and so
we have two
programs we have the Alliance which is a
thousand dollars a year and then we have
a mastermind which is seventy five
hundred so we have about sixty members
in the mastermind and then about like a
hundred in the Alliance so my question
is I've really gotten good at the
content creation side of things I've
really studied it I'm taking Peng Joon's
courses so I've been really good at it
and what we've discussed as a team is
potentially creating content for our
mastermind members trying to transition
them from the mastermind into creating
content for them and helping them with
their SOA and things like that because
it's very important to stay in front of
your audience especially for once so I'm
trying to like communicate the
importance to them so how would you
transition people from one of those
types of courses to some like like a
content creation plan for them or what
we're doing I mean well I mean are you
looking to convert them to somebody
who's paying you $3,000 a month retainer
or yeah yes so we wanted to be like a
monthly subscription we were thinking
around like $1500 a month I don't know
how you feel about that as well you can
I mean the martyr you know listen
$15 a month 15,000 a month you know they
all play no I understand okay like I
said $15 a month or a fifteen thousand a
month it just comes down to you know
supply demand quality you know the
belief of the quality I mean if people
wanted monthly content for me it's gonna
you know it's thirty thousand a month
when we did that for being their talent
like you know comes in a lot of
different ways so I think that um the
reality is that I think you need to
create the information around what
you're trying to do to that master might
what I would probably do you said there
were 60 people right yeah I would
probably invite all 60 of them into a
zoom and and spend two three hours
explaining that you guys are gonna be
rolling this out in three months and
answering questions and let them all
hear it and over three hours build up
the smoke to get an opportunity to do
something that's a great idea
Thank You Mickey um also I followed
Dirac and babban a lot I was just
wondering what kind of is your like your
content creation process behind the
scenes like do you cuz for me a lot of
our stuff is leveraged out cuz it's just
me like for content creation so I
leveraged out like our graphics our
subtitles and stuff like that what is
the process for you guys
meaning do we have it in-house or do we
outsource there yeah it's all in-house
all right now there's there's a 30
person team on Team Gary so it's loaded
what do you think the benefits are that
for little tests like subtitles and
graphics because I'm teaching those kids
I'm paying those kids and then I'm
putting and then I'm letting them grow
into bigger careers whether on my team
whether in vaynermedia or whether they
use the clout of being with me to go on
and do other things for themselves okay
so do you Rex might cost me more but it
but it builds a family and builds a
community okay so okay that's very
important okay yep well because I'm
playing long-term but it's maybe not the
most financial thing because I can go to
fiber I can go to work well for us we're
a smaller business source I think you're
going down the right path but as but the
leader needs to think about really
investing in it long term and start
adding some overhead to build that
culture okay awesome take your partner
thank you dr. sue big shout out to Bob
brand nikhil regular milk Gregory
Millard Gregg Ruben what's good Bay Area
getting up early Luke you started
alluding to its where I was going you
know the affluent you know customers
start saying yo let me put some money in
chirp-chirp chirp-chirp and everything
that got you from one to eight locations
now you change up the script because you
got to expand faster which I so it's not
about expanding it's not that we want to
expand faster it's more - yes well right
but not not because of na
because of chirping and all that it's
more because we work seven days a week
we have that fire inside of us that we
just want to keep going we want to get
our brand out to it more people because
we know that we we have something
different to offer than any other barber
shop that we that we come in contact
with right eight successful locations
like my biggest problem is if you want
to start direct-to-consumer [ __ ]
razors and [ __ ] shaving cream or
create some sort of other revenue source
you're gonna get distracted right so the
thing is that the profit margins are
very low in this industry profit profit
margins are low in a lot of industries
you know bad profit margins are in the
wine business
they suck [ __ ] so so what was your what
was your way of getting past that being
okay and doing a lot more revenue
[ __ ] things across the East Coast and
[ __ ] making more even you listen
razor thin margins at scale become real
money of course so that's the thing how
do you get to scale when the margins
right now are so small or you stay
patient which you innovate and start
another revenue stream that allows you
to not have to take outside capital you
want to be a part we want to be a brand
you want to be like a lifestyle brand
that's right that's what our main goal
and focus is for the future is to
transition into a lifestyle brand we
understand that the draw is the haircuts
that's how we're gonna draw people in is
with our high quality haircuts great
customer service a great team of barbers
and and a great team of management
ownership but with that that's we want
to eventually transition into being a
lifestyle but we through these years and
through the through the time of us
building our business we've learned a
lot
and and that's the thing is sometimes
we're not sure whether to go back to to
help others grow with our model or to
just stay focused on our model and
continue to grow and conceits a blue
traps slowly Brown right right now is
the greatest era of everybody trying to
make money giving advice to others based
on minimal or like some early success
what do you start mastermind so that's a
chirping you hear all the time oh it's
about it's about education right now
it's about this it's about that and it's
a gift the problem is that that you know
it takes a lot to run business a lot of
a lot of people think that barber shops
are absentee businesses and that's just
not true it can be if you check
there's no absentee business show me an
absentee that's about to go out of
business exactly that's what I tell
people who want to open up barber shops
I say I work seven days a week okay and
I'm not even a barber
I don't cut hair my you're not exactly I
work seven days a week to manage each
one of our barber shops into to deal
with any issues that come along to coach
our barbers through the good and the bad
okay if you think that you're just going
to open up a barber shop and let it run
itself then you're sadly mistaken if you
think that you're gonna compete with
anyone that even comes close to what we
did there's no passive income the way
there's no passive income the way people
dream it up you could have a you could
have a business that kicks cash every
month but if your buildings with rent
you're gonna have to manage that what
happens when somebody burns the [ __ ]
building down when there's a crime at
your building what happens when the
person that's managing your building
dies and you have to replace him or her
like people are confused out here this
is work so that's the thing when you
have employees and when it's brick and
mortar like this there's it's not smooth
sailing all the time and that takes away
a lot of time to be able to do a lot
more things that you want to do you know
there's only so many hours a day and
trust me I go I listen to you all the
time and I'm with you on the fact that
I'll work 18 hours straight if I have to
I don't care okay and it's just a matter
love love it I love it I love it I left
you know I thank him and I worked in
retail and I just love being an
entrepreneur I love working I don't I
don't even care if I don't take a
paycheck
I went months years without taking even
even even a paycheck you know I and
that's the thing is is we love and it's
not only me it's myself my partner's my
brother my Isaac Sean our partners Ryan
we devote so much to the business and we
wanted to see it grow so much and that's
thing I get I guess what you're saying
is just slow down and and and - it's a
reason you're 34 yes so 34 is when I
left Wine Library day-to-day and started
vaynermedia I had no money I literally
started vaynermedia in the conference
room of Buddy Media cuz me and AJ had no
money I literally started at zero all
over I didn't make a lot of money
building my dad's business for him and
then whatever I saved I invested in
Facebook and Twitter so I felt good
about the future but it wasn't liquid
for a long time so I had to build this
business and and look where I'm at now
at 44 like you're just starting Joe like
what are you gonna be one of those
douchebag entrepreneurs on Instagram so
expanding into a monster lifestyle brand
you're doing it right so many people are
gonna lose in this era for doing it
right getting up a notch poking up their
head because they've been head down
you're like you know all these people
are having fun while these people are
moving fast all these people are getting
more I'm [ __ ] working seven days a
week bleeding and all these people are
[ __ ] selling [ __ ] and [ __ ]
winning what am I doing wrong did it it
did it I gotta learn how to raise
capital
I got to expand quicker we gotta [ __ ]
to create a mastermind or a [ __ ]
course we're gonna teach other small
business like when people come to us and
say hey we got money we
want to invest in in this brand and we
pretty much turned them down all every
single time do you think we're doing the
right thing potentially I mean look
there are there is smart money out there
there's somebody who's passive who
doesn't give a [ __ ] who just wants to
believe so much in you who's not gonna
bother you and who doesn't have a board
seat and doesn't have say they're just
getting dividends kicked out in the
future if you can get money that's
passive you know that's chill and that's
maybe you know when Equinox took money
from Steve Ross because he owned a lot
of buildings that helped him with the
real estate expansion you take a real
estate mogul with a ton of money
who's she or he's got a ton of buildings
around the world might be an interesting
plank because also you're paying smaller
rent you know like there's there's all
sorts of ways to think about it
money isn't always bad but money for the
sake of money is bad because I also
think a lot of people think that the
barber industry is very cashed rich and
they're gonna just it's gonna be a cash
cow and that's first of all we we accept
credit card so I wouldn't worry about
what everybody's perceptions are I would
stay your course stay patient look you
can there's a lot of ways to make money
wine library's margins were [ __ ]
what did I do I started buying wines
that were extremely good that nobody
knew and I was able to make me a margin
on it reality is if your brands pop and
so heavy every haircut could go up a
dollar maybe they could like a dollar is
a dollar like the reality is you could
now it could be a recession and you
might have to go down a dollar you know
like you know but like you could you
know people people get away from the
basics you guys built on the basics I
believe that there's no way you would be
here without it
based on the story I heard so you know
my dollar extra cut starts to change
business god this show is [ __ ]
awesome just having the time to explain
[ __ ] it's good for me too because it
allows me to show you that deeper level
that I'm actually operating in a lot of
times have to be in like surface level
headlines it's there it's formats
bringing it out hi Margaret hi Gary
hi my kids say hi hi kids
okay so yeah I said two questions in the
first question you did not answer but
the second question you guys picked me
up on and we are starting to listen to
your show every morning now we're in
Toronto and the kids are asking mummy
where does he sware so much and I said
today and I said oh you know Gary's from
New York everyone in New York stalks
like that yeah I identify a lot with the
lady who called in yesterday be the
lawyer who had you know a lot of money
and so on and I'm 49 this year and I'm a
divorced mother of two boys they are
eleven and seven we have a very good
relationship with their dad now so we're
very friendly we talk a lot and so we're
all in a good place I also run a like a
global marketing strategy agency and
we're doing a lot of high margin stuff
right now but my question today has to
do with the harder task of raising
children yes so my question is how do
you motivate how do you generate that
intrinsic motivation and very
intelligent children you know that we
have you know nine ten eleven year olds
with their own e-commerce sites now they
design it on the Apple system they these
kids they understand about blockchain
about AI a are
like 3d printing biotech they know a lot
of knowledge they're actually
intelligence wise probably smarter than
many adults I fully believe that to be
true yeah so so the thing is we've got
these really intelligent kids and I and
I started like a separate passion
project just to introduce them to more
technology jobs of the future and that's
another company that I have just to
expose them more to that but how do you
motivate these children to use their
intelligence for good
to make positive change in the world you
know stuff that you're working on how do
you get people to share more to love
more to bring humanity to the next level
by suffocating bad behavior the current
generation of parents are are being too
passive around punishment and forcing
kids to learn how to make money the
reality is is we have a very rich world
in the macro because there's a lot of
cash in the system can you hear me yep
okay so I believe the way you do it is
through suffocating I for you know one
of the ways to get people to focus on
kindness and caring is to pay punished
when they're deploying the opposite and
be clapping and putting on a pedestal
when they're doing great behavior we're
all just animals and when you're raising
an animal positive and negative
reinforcement creates frameworks we
don't have enough accountability for bad
behavior and we do not have enough glory
for kind behavior it's the same way of
how to build hunger in kids stop buying
them things literally my mom was like
you now buy your own stuff and that was
tough because Nintendo was expensive and
Sega was expensive and we we have an
entitled generation and we don't have
and we
have repercussions you know we don't
have you know we haven't created a free
more the kids will get punished anymore
the [ __ ] like if your kids a dick can
you punish him for two weeks to take
away his phone I had a funny feeling
that he's gonna think about kindness
more okay we we don't have a world where
there's the parenting structure of today
and this is macro talk obviously there's
a lot of different parents doing a lot
of different things but in the macro the
biggest thing that I'm observing one
man's point of view is we need we need
kids to realize that there are
repercussions for bad behavior and and
and the opposite when your son opens the
door for an elderly lady and you spend
an entire week talking about how
remarkable that was that's a
reinforcement of kind behavior I was
reinforced as a child and others that I
see that are extremely passionate about
kindness were reinforced in a culture in
their home or their environment that
really put kindness on a pedestal but
not to the level of delusion or ideology
or altruism that wasn't practical
it wasn't like hippie [ __ ] it was
kindness [ __ ] yeah I think that you know
if we are to move the human race in the
a positive direction and you know
there's so many things going on from
from global warming to species
extinction to poverty to the digital
divide I mean if we are to move the
human race forward I mean you and I we
have another maybe 40 years to go 50
years if the topic should be more than
40 84 would piss me the [ __ ] off I'd be
like God what the [ __ ] I had some more
[ __ ] to do yeah so it's really you know
the way that we raise the next
generation and and you know the sky's
the limit for for Humanity the other way
really think about raising the next
generation is through action you know
one of the one of the most glorious
things that's happened in my career is
over the last three or four years I
became cool on Instagram too a lot of
young people and then I spent my time
talking about things like caring and
empathy and kindness and patience and
all of a sudden those words are in the
lexicon now watching like twenty
two-year-old tough-guy entrepreneurs
talk about empathy is maybe the most
gratifying thing in my life and so you
know the it's not only on the micro it's
it's in our behavior as well and what we
put out we set the tone through our
actions and so I think I think a lot of
grown-ups need to lean into kindness and
caring and lack of judgment I see tons
of parents on Twitter and Facebook
judging the [ __ ] out of people who they
don't even know and then and then
yelling at their kids to be kinder that
doesn't [ __ ] work yeah yeah that's
good you know like just the hypocrisy of
parenting parenting I see parents all
day long talk about their fear of
technology but then when they're having
a nice glass of wine with friends they
give the iPad to the kid so they don't
bother them that's not working your kids
being trained to know you're full of
[ __ ] Yee so we have to be very
thoughtful on how we roll so it's it's
more about not even just having the hard
conversations as you said but also doing
the hard things first a hundred percent
the conversations kids read through that
they're too smart you know it's how you
back it up it's why punishing matters
you can't just be like a little Ricky I
don't want you to say that anymore you
take a phone away from a child you take
their phone out of their [ __ ] hand
when they're rude to somebody and you
take them put into your purse for a week
watch your kid value kindness more okay
thank you thank you have a great day you
too that's why I love the streets
there's repercussions out there you do
the wrong thing you punched the
[ __ ] mouth kids need more to that
parents need to be doing hey Gary how's
it going it's going super well my man
what's your name where you from my name
is George I'm 23 and I'm from Wisconsin
George it was funny because yesterday in
the show you were talking about
animation and I use animation for
education
my passion is science education but a
little bit of backstory I am a visual
learner and I used to create graphics
for me to learn during class and in
December I realized that my passion is
sharing this so I hit tik-tok a hit
Instagram I hit all the social medias
and I started just sharing and I
realized I had such a passion for it I
wake up every day and worked six seven
hours creating creating creating and
sharing you know I have a Shopify
account and I have all this forms of
media but the thing is is that I spend
most of my time creating the graphics
the majority of the people that do this
kind of thing online show about 10% of
what they create and leave the rest 90%
behind a paywall and I mean it's like I
can do that but it tugs on my
heartstrings because I don't don't do I
don't want to do it I want to hear
that's why you like me
I don't do it either and it's just like
I just don't it's like I'm out of
balance cuz I don't know what to do now
I got good news
don't do it the [ __ ] does anybody else's
life have to do with you wouldn't gonna
be sad that somebody not as good as you
makes a lot more money than you money
ain't [ __ ] okay do you have any advice
for how to make it sustainable
like Adam yes with it how about doing
what I do I give to the world but I have
corporate clients okay that's one way
you could also do a I love the idea of
somebody this creative doing like a fair
like literally like a like a like a you
can do live events where you do like one
or two events a year where everybody
comes in and you make money on that
event not monetizing your audience is a
very powerful you know
opportunity if you're good at making
money outside of them and so corporate
clients you can get into merchandising I
think merchandising is a very fair play
my big thing is like if you're kind I
have some merchandise but the main work
is the graphics understood now so but
but the reality is is that if you listen
you're like me if you don't feel excited
if it doesn't feel right to your
chemicals on monetizing their audience
that way then you do it a different way
and there is no right or wrong it's not
like listen monetizing an audience is
more than fine it's capitalism nobody
forced those people to buy but I'm with
you I think a lot of people think
they're helping audiences but what
they're putting out is manipulative
content only to get you to pay yeah and
I struggle with that during this time of
social distancing in quarantine I've
been holding live events where I do
study with me videos and I record the
process on YouTube you have any other
advice for things I can do during this
time that everyone's studying at home
you know I think it's a time listen one
of the ways that you'll win is by
building a brand and then you're able to
monetize different ways maybe get paid
to speak for $25,000 maybe you get a TV
show like there's a lot of things that
could happen for you so for you if
you're not gonna monetize the audience I
think your number one thing is to give
back to the audience could also build
your brand so for me when I'm most
worried about right now is what are you
doing on Pinterest what are you doing on
tick-tock what are you doing on YouTube
for me this is about broadening your
brand you you're so young you can build
a lot of equity in your brand over time
and then convert it I'm posting every
day on Instagram I'm posting a lot on
Pinterest I post five to six times on
tick-tock I'm six times ever or five to
six times a day a day I love that how's
that going it's going really good I've
got about 30,000 followers on tick-tock
30,000 followers on Instagram I'm trying
to learn how to use LinkedIn for my type
of approach of that so you're listening
to me clearly yeah every day
so what are you what are your handles
Dustin listen to this my youtube is
doodles in the membrane right now for
Instagram YouTube
tick tock it's all the same those in the
membrane
yeah uh you and do you sell anything
ever yeah I saw some merchandise I have
some sweaters I have some stickers um
I've got an idea I think you can sell a
one-day zoom event you know 450 people
at a premium cost where you go super
deep and you go one-on-one because what
you're doing is like for me like for
example this right here is valuable like
if I did this for you with an for an
hour
you'd pay and not be mad at me even
though I did I do it for free because
it's so not scalable so I don't do it
it's I can't make it worth my while but
nobody would be mad at me for one hour
consultations it's no different than a
therapist or a chiropractor or anything
else I do think you or a class like a
yoga instructor I do think that you have
the permission I could tell your spirit
so it makes me confident in this I think
you should try to do a VIP class eight
hours 50 people one eight hours you see
where I'm going yeah you overwhelm them
now you're like only fifty people eight
hours [ __ ] everybody's gonna go get
gotten to and I have a feeling it could
do really well and it's the kind of
thing that you could you know really do
well with and make a couple hundred you
know bucks per head or five hundred
bucks per head and it could be quite
meaningful you know you get three
hundred bucks per head on that fifty it
starts adding up yeah 15 G's quick how
many followers how many subscribers do
you have on YouTube I have about 4,000 I
think all right not a bunch more
yesterday that awesome dude with the red
beard bar what for like 38,000 Don James
Sammy just signed up by the way talk
about something that is really valuable
for parents right now for their kids
they're trying to find activities you
might have one of the most important
channel you know channels yeah one of
the things I'm trying to do the most is
I'm not trying to come out my YouTube
and all my social medias as I know and
you don't I'm trying to come at it as
you know I'm a friend studying with you
at the library and your demeanor your
Energy's [ __ ] off the charts bro
thanks man thanks you're gonna win can I
give you a good good piece of advice
yeah live stupidly humbly like super
humble like shitty like shitty
for like three four years I'm a funny
feeling it's gonna work out for you
thanks you don't have expenses you'll
stay patient and you'll really crush
okay you see we're doing yeah if you can
keep your overhead down live at home
live with six buddies you know by
[ __ ] ramen you know like yeah if you
can go there it will let you go really
patient in this process I'm a very
intuitive dude dude I really think
you've got it
thank you thank you man means a lot
Thanks secure yourself you do love you I
love you back Diana what's good TJ
what's good Mandy Reed Alabama it's
what's up
berry eyes and I thank you lean overhead
is right on that Facebook comment what's
going on Twitter Oh John law what's good
hello Gary thanks for having me on so
thanks for being on the show bro
okay from I'm from Bay Area California
hold
so to give some context I'm 14 and you
know building businesses in creating
content and making money that's like my
thing that's what I do that's what I'd
love to do and I spend all my time doing
that but if you right now I'm working on
probably six different businesses I'm
doing three selling ecommerce you know
affiliate marketing some graphic design
freelancing I'm writing ebooks hiring
ghost writers to do ebooks like all this
stuff and I feel like my energy is
getting split between them to the point
that all of them are being less
successful than they could otherwise be
and I enjoy all of them so that's not a
problem but in terms of the the
potential of the businesses the long
term how do you think do you think I
should downsize or keep going at all of
them go wider so 14 this is the Eternity
ship plus a lot of these businesses John
you're gonna look back at when you were
25 me like I was a scummy kid because
right now the money is the thing that
you're chasing and I want you to learn
process I promise on everything I got
because I'm good with
intuition you're gonna be embarrassed
that you built some of these businesses
cuz you know they were just built for
the arbitrage of money but I like that
you're learning the process so I don't
think you have to go all-in on any of
them I have a funny feeling you're far
more destined in 10 years to build
something quite meaningful right now is
the year of the Taoiseach okay you're
learning reps right now my man okay and
a more specific question about Instagram
so I'm building - I'm building a
personal brand with on two accounts on
Instagram few separate accounts and then
I also have two accounts that are niche
pages - all posted motivational content
of stuff and that takes a lot of time
and it feels like almost because it's
not a personal brand it doesn't really
reflect on myself
and I I'm I'm not sure if it's really
yeah you'd sell them off tell them okay
so you know some - some of those
Pakistani and hustlers that hit me up
everyday and all the other people that
buy pages get rid of those okay what do
you what do you so I get it cuz I'm you
at 14 business business business is
there other things you give a [ __ ] about
like music or sport or like fashion or
anything else yeah well I definitely am
into sports um I played sports
year-round pretty much I'm competitive
doing competitively doing crossfit and
one of the one of my personal accounts
on Instagram is the fitness page so I'm
really into that kind of stuff but other
than that I feel like is the stuff that
goes into the businesses is a lot more
than just think it's many different
things that I'm interested in that go
into that I would learn everything about
art and science right what I mean by
that is run ads on every platform you
make content on every platform don't
necessarily outsource for scale just get
dangerous in art and science it's a very
good skill set for you in the next 100
years of your life and do you think at
this point I should be focusing solely
on businesses or like I heard you saying
a while ago that you
there have that two weeks during summer
to go hang out with friends should I
just see John just so you know I didn't
even have cell phones so like when I
went in my cocoon I really wanted my
cocoon but if I had social media and
cell phones a house party in this [ __ ] I
probably would have not had yet like bro
I worked every day like if you hung out
one weekend before this quarantine thing
then you were ready like so don't get my
advice twisted you might be getting you
know that friend time I really worked
for like like like literally imagine no
Korona normal [ __ ] and the day that you
end you know school this year you
literally go and work 12 hours a day in
a liquor store then come home sleep and
then go work again and then literally do
that every day until you come back to
school like that's what I did you're
doing it for yourself like I got to get
a couple of weekends here near during
the school year for baseball cards shows
but like yeah I mean look it I think you
should enjoy your youth and have some
friend time but working on your skill
matters like we all look up to Beyonce
and LeBron guess what they didn't have
normal childhoods if you really want to
go there you got to put in the work but
I do think a little fun is great plus
you were blessed with or dude your name
is [ __ ] amazing the whole chats
exploding they're like his name's Johnny
log be like you're [ __ ] sepra you can
just modifies your name your whole life
bro listen to me do me one favor don't
be a scum bucket and what I mean by that
is right now you know this there's
people at 14 year old who loves
entrepreneurship Instagram is littered
with [ __ ] douchebags that talk about
the lifestyle not the principles of
doing good kindness businesses promise
me that you don't chase the dollars
chase the process right now and learn
how to be honorable app because I
promise you Johnny if you remember
anything I [ __ ] ever tell you how you
make your money is way more important
than how much you make thank you promise
me it can it can catch you young dude
the lifestyle the nightlife the guys the
girls like I get it but I'm telling you
I'm telling you
promise me because you know how I'm
different than some of the other voices
that are out there please stay the
course on this I I will I will do you
understand what I'm saying
yes yes good okay thank you
talk to you soon all right
I'm really in it today bad news I got a
drop in 22 minutes I've got some
business thing that popped up so 10:30
today you know hi can you hear me I
could hear you oh I know you're trying
to do this yesterday but it really like
wasn't going through today it is what's
your name where you from uh my name is
Ashley I'm actually from New York and oh
my hip you said that Linda but I
actually lived in New York City right
now so okay yeah Chad is that um thank
you so much for everything you have been
an inspiration for a lot I have been
following you so I do really appreciate
that thank you um I guess my question to
you is like you always talk about your
parents and how they've had like such a
big impact on your life and they've kind
of been like that framework and
helping you just really become who you
are today like my I guess my question
was what advice you have for people who
really don't have that framework but
you're super ambitious and they really
like want that direction
yeah like how do I feel about you know
listen I'll be very honest with you my
dad didn't have it and my dad put that
chip on his shoulder and went and used
the energy in a different way right so
listen there's unlimited people that are
kind and crushing the world who didn't
have parents they looked up to and so
you know I feel comfortable talking
about all the blessings I was given but
I always remind people if one person
made it that looks like you then you can
too so hey you know first it's about not
dwelling the biggest thing that people
you know I love how your head went off
on that right like the number one thing
that I see is people dwelling about [ __ ]
they couldn't control right like you
don't get to pick your parents you don't
get to pick where you're born you know
it's so to me the second you move into
optimism and gratitude Oh gratitude and
optimism go team I like something I
think I got a hoodie go gratitude and
optimism this second it's crazy my brain
just click [ __ ] that's amazing like when
your mindset is gratitude an optimist
then you can go definitely
when you're when you're dwelling and
looking back you're [ __ ] stuck
forever so so you know sometimes you get
the fortunate thing to look up to a
parent sometimes you get the fortunate
thing of looking up to a grandparent an
uncle a best friend a best friend's
parent somebody saw on TV somebody you
watch on the Internet
it's about bleeding into positivity
that's the it's rash like honestly it's
about what you put into your ears and
through your eyes is your life no I
definitely learned that and I feel like
through my life I've gained a lot of
experience like I've ended up I'm like
you just start saying like I've worked
since I was like 11 12 my mom passed
away around that time and I've been
working since then and I feel like I've
had older brothers older everybody and
people who always like hey like you're
super wise like you're kind of the one
to look to but it's like I'm the
youngest out of everybody like who do I
look to and so shall we
yourself look within yourself you know I
give a lot of gaps to my parents but let
me promise you it's all been of myself
in my own head yeah I think it's just
like balancing that that sense of like
confidence but also that humility like
you said though I don't know no no no
stick with me stick me I like where this
is going that's gonna help a lot of
people I'm as confident as it gets but
you can be humble like you know if you
know like if you're worried about that
part the other part is don't put rules
on you like what a lot when you're the
youngest and you were born as an old
wise soul and it's and it's on your
shoulders like you're gonna get us out
you're the one that's gonna do it don't
put a time limit on it you know don't
put don't put that pressure like like
you got to live for you and the more you
live for you if it goes then other
people will benefit you can't worry
about outside forces
okay listen yesh I'm not letting you go
because I feel like there's more work to
be done here listen to me
then you keep playing with me here what
else what do you like what are you
really thinking like what's what's
[ __ ] with you to help me help me help
you what
some real unreal [ __ ] I think just
getting out of my own way I have a lot
of really do have a lot of really I
think I do have a lot of people who are
like behind me immediately I don't
really have like a super big following
on Instagram but just person a person I
worked in detail I worked in food I've
worked in just like a lot of these
personable industries and I find that a
lot of people just gravitate towards my
energy but it's like I just don't know
what to give back out what do you do
like what do you make can you make
content I wanted to start doing that
YouTube channel because you are you are
you able to do design and video work I
wanted to get in there for the most part
I was drawing and painting and whatnot
but I wanted to get more in the digital
realm and just I used my face as a
platform for myself so I don't know job
I was working at a restaurant but since
the whole covin thing and that I was a
manager before that but I just
completely tapped out of that role
because again I realized like you can
get a certain amount of money do you
think you can write I I said I was gonna
start journaling today I have that
journal yeah yeah yeah are you good at
ideas I think so how much of my content
have you consumed um I've consumed it
over the years but I know you definitely
have like a cult following that's not
yeah but you have a general sense of
what I'm talking about
definitely listen me I really really
really really think you should email me
I think you should work on my team at
vaynermedia Ballou v-dub I'm being dead
[ __ ] serious I'm super [ __ ]
serious - yeah be like okay just so do
me a favor I want you to email me at
Gary at vaynermedia right now and I want
you to put in the title hey it's me
Ashley the girl from New York we're in
the Atlanta hoodie got you I got you I
got you thank you so much my hands are
like shaking listen to me I'm Mike
my team you have to make ideas you have
to write and you have to make videos or
pictures the drawing interests me you
see that you don't follow me enough to
maybe know this but I like putting
cartoons in my content I think we could
do drawings I'm gonna have an D or D
Rock or CID or May or Katie reach out to
you today after you email me and we're
gonna start giving you some stuff to see
what you can make and then and then in
the next couple of weeks or maybe when
this is over we're gonna [ __ ] hire
you can be on my team
that's the ready whatever you need I got
you
thank you so much
Dustin yes sir you just you just met
your new teammate looking forward to
working together you saw that coming
from a mile away right I think one I
think the people in the comments saw way
before the I did they were like here
comes here comes and I was like what
here's what comes in and then I they
clicked for me we're giving out jobs
giving out jobs there's something I feel
about her I feel like she needs us and
then we'll figure out how to get her to
help us very cool very cool indeed
Craig beautiful you love Kobe I love
Kobe man alright because that's my smart
guy my inspiration there it's just so
devastating I can't believe he's not
with us huge man--huge but he is he is
man I think he's in all of us whatever I
think that's right he left real impact
that's real true mister said it right
Craig what can help you it all right
here's the thing I our time from playing
ball like a 2008 right I'll 2018 and one
thing about it man like I feel like a
lot of guys know like no judgment but
like I don't want to get on here to try
to like prove that I'm cool or prove
that you know people you know sure rock
with me I feel like that me that's me in
a nature thanks man thanks but what I
what I've been struggling with since I
retired man I like I've always been an
entrepreneur by heart like even my plan
career man if you if you found out how I
started plan you wouldn't believe it bro
this is its crazy story you hustle bit
yeah man I literally I was working at I
was going a 24 hour fitness training
with some friends and I want to play pro
I had a guy that was playing the turkey
making crazy money but I love the game I
always want to prove to like coaches
everyone
I was like a mid-level player man I know
I didn't play at a big school I just had
the chip on my shoulder like you know
played a d3 in Texas but I'm like I'm
going pro I I want to make this just cuz
I love to play and uh man I was working
and a guy came in played baseball but he
came in with like his friend a nice
chick and by the end of the conversation
man I was he's actually like dude you be
what are you doing working in a
restaurant what are you doing working at
a steakhouse
and I was like got good personality man
and I like one so I end up you know
waiting on a man and this was actually
my last like straw basically I had
spilled some [ __ ]
it just wasn't one quality that manager
was kicking you out sure for she got it
man but at the end of the night the last
table guy came in you know just real
cool guy man I totally working to save
up money to go to a camp interview just
to give myself a shot I heard about this
cap on you know I was like let me get
out the bucket because at that point you
knew that Europe overseas had some money
and that was more likely to be where you
were gonna play it just was like I did
the deal II tried to be leader out yep I
heard it was immediate at the end of it
like literally Nick nurse Nick nurse was
the coach at the RGV Vipers at the time
and he set me down and he was real and
he was like listen your talent level can
be X amount but you have high level guys
I think it was Chris lost and on the
board you have all these names that I
have to sell to these guys above me
while we should take them so no matter
what your talent level is these guys are
gonna stand out more I said okay I get I
literally I took a bus from Houston down
to the valley my agent called me is like
they want you to work out tomorrow I did
they're like in a day just because I
love the game I love to play but yeah
man I met him and by the end of the
dinner man of God just like he wrote me
it for like nine hundred bucks the
bomber plane ticket I had already made
enough to bait pay for the camp so
winning over there man killed it and you
know kind of the rest was history man so
chatter I played I played in Germany
Saudi Arabia Cyprus you know Mexico you
know basically got a chance to see the
world
good for you I'll tell you my first NIC
I made probably about the entire season
probably about 600 euros I get it like
okay what can I answer before I bounce
so so basically what I'm trying to
figure out man I'm getting stuck between
I tried so many different things I went
to the car business
I did a really well in that moved up in
science because I know I need money and
I'm always motivated by that so what I'm
getting stuck between I want to continue
that aspect I started a trucking company
and I've been doing that and at the same
time I teach like I train and I teach
kids so I love to do both man but what
I'm stuck between is trying to figure
that out trying to figure out how can I
you know build my business my trucking
company and at the same time give the
game back because that gives me like the
joy so you taught between happiness and
cash that's what's happening like you've
got the business because that's what you
you get it you got your life you got a
lifestyle you want to live but the games
so deep in your [ __ ] soul and you want
to [ __ ] give back and do that but the
money is not as much there a couple
things to think about are you the only
business owner apart is a partnership no
it's just me right now you might want to
consider one of the things I see in
these scenarios is you might want to
bring in somebody who and give him 30%
of the business they have to earn into
it you give him 5 points every year for
6 years but she or he could run that
business all of a sudden you got
somebody who gives a [ __ ] about the
business cuz they got nothing now there
coming up and they're gonna work hard to
get to that 30% ownership somebody you
know somebody you get to know maybe an
employee a manager you know what what
have you which then allows you to
actually go all in I'll be honest with
you with this level of charisma and swag
and looks I think you could be I think
you could be I think you could really
build a basketball academy virtual
business where you train individual kids
but then like like the ship we all grew
up with the VHS tapes tapes on [ __ ]
cable you can now be doing that as a
class online and people are you know
paying 19 bucks a month to get the
content and to get 3 hours with you in a
zoom I'm really pushing through people
heavy on the zoom and Google Hangouts
you could have a hundred people a night
in a zoom three hours worth of questions
do that two nights a week I mean there's
there's a lot of opportunity for
somebody with this kind of personality
tree and this kind of passion I'm
convinced by the way Craig this is on
some real [ __ ] I'm convinced you would
make more money in the basketball thing
than the trucking company it's just that
you have to deploy massive humility for
seven years
what are you needed by that just get
into it you're not gonna make as much
money the first seven years but by
you're eight you'll make more so your
lifestyle adjustments would have to map
that because you don't give a [ __ ] about
the trucking [ __ ] you're [ __ ] making
the ROI the money and I respect that but
I really really think you got a look at
monetizing the basketball thing one on
one training and virtual content I think
you could build a real business so
here's my only hiccup on that and I rent
it that my daughter I have a daughter
okay I have a family so yes I know I
took a backseat like literally like I
took the COBE approach I read her
interview what Kobe was like you know he
felt like he was he can make up you know
bounds over other guys when he first
came in Lee cuz he didn't have a family
he didn't he didn't have to habla gate
that time to do it so for me it's like I
literally man that's what I adapted when
he came I was in a gym eight hours a day
I knew I looked not naturally good
enough so I want to work harder and get
better and get become like a
perfectionist actually like learn the
craft like the movements everything so
that you know that takes time that's how
I am when it comes to everything when it
the business now apathy I feel like if I
want to blow it up I know what I have to
do I have to really walk in and knock it
out so sometimes it feels like how do
you spread just if you're a
perfectionist on both sides like like
how do you make that happen
by starting the process to not judge
yourself you got to get perfectionism is
[ __ ] it's fear it's a disguise
people use it as a disguise bro
perfectionism is an excuse I'm telling
you it is perfectionism is [ __ ]
insecurity with lipstick on don't judge
yourself if you if you're in the gym all
day and you got hot you figured
something out and you came late and you
missed that dinner that you bring dinner
make it up next week make it up next
week take her for a walk
spend the whole day with her like
everybody is making it like everyone's
judging themselves yeah don't judge
yourself in a day judge yourself in a
life I got you bro hey you my brother I
listen to you every day and I hear your
voice started and it just like pushes me
man like thank you all right Dustin
let's wrap this up last five minutes
great show sorry it's 30 minutes shorter
today but I really appreciate it I
thought we did some real stuff today man
there was some real stuff we gave away a
job we gave out some advice it was a 14
year old the ladies started off right
that so we might have to go with four
ladies in a row next time too like they
started off right and then we came in
with the 14 year olds and we gave out a
job we did a lot of stuff today dust I
felt really good about this show I
really did you know we didn't do we
didn't sign up anybody for white text
that [ __ ] updated us let's get that up
there it is today in an hour and a half
if you don't sign up before the text
goes out you just missed the whole day
so right now as you wrap up if you buy
wine on the internet if you buy one on
the Internet flatout sign up for wine
text today's rose' is
super crazy good super crazy good crazy
discount on it too so definitely check
that out
I just appreciate all of you let me give
a couple little shoutouts before we're
out hockey wraps softie what's good
appreciate you signing up yesterday
Junior Richard what's good team Garrity
with that but Paul Russ really good show
I hope that you took some value out of
this I've been really enjoying the show
I'm really enjoying bringing value I
really adore it all of you please take a
screenshot oh if you sign up for wine
Tech's right now when you get to final
thank you screen take a picture tweet me
at it
I want to follow you right now let's
wrap with that if you do that and it's
just a good show please uh please hit me
up on Twitter with your favorite moments
from the show and also throughout the
two one to Dustin if you want to get on
the show
text me two one two nine three one five
seven three one two one two nine three
one five seven three one text your
question and put hashtag tea with Gary
Vee and the team will reach out to you
and put you on the show
hit me up with Twitter with your
highlights facebook youtube linkedin
thank you so much for watching instagram
what's good I really appreciate it let
me read a couple of comments here before
we're out mommy thank you so much
Matthias thank you John law Fitness John
law good job today
honey la cama guar what's good
Julio Espinoza in the building
all right everybody have a wonderful
wonderful wonderful day I'm gonna spend
two minutes following you guys on
Twitter so yeah thanks Dustin
okay so team Gary has made a lot of
content over the years but what's your
favorite piece of content those makes a
great question
my favorite content by far is I'm
considering doing a vaynermedia
operation stay-at-home day once a week
forever because I'm I'm pretty sold that
I've gotten more done per day than
sometimes at a month